[Music]
[Applause]
for example toddlers and tiaras I was
watching toddlers and tiaras the other
day and then I hit the info button and
this is what it said it said whiney
immature brats who craved the spotlight
and their children the talking dead I
checked out the talking dead and I press
the info button and it said the show for
people who like the walking dead but
don't have friends to discuss it ESPN
SportsCenter was on I was watching that
and then I hit the info button and it
said a constantly repeating loop of
basketball dunks touchdowns homeruns and
other metaphors for gay sex duck dynasty
I was watching duck dynasty the other
day and then I hit the info button and
it said colorful banter between living
breathing tick ecosystems
the gold Birds that show on ABC the
Goldbergs I was watching the Goldbergs
and then I hit the info button it said
bet you anything Mel Gibson's not
watching the talk I watched the show
that talked and then I hit the info
button and it said james Van Der Beek is
held hostage by a group of women who
think they're on the view I saw this
show 10 million dollar Bigfoot bounty
yeah great show on Spike and then I hit
the info button it said still no sign of
Bigfoot but hey we found Dean Cain I
don't you've seen the show chop but
that's a pretty good show and then I hit
the info button and it said a bunch of
people will run a cooking show with all
the fun and lightness of the Nuremberg
trials yeah the thing that happened in
history let's move on to Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills I hit the button and it
said recently unearthed rare and
fascinating al Qaeda recruitment video
I defy you not to hate America what the
hell
now I just want to keep watching the
next show screw the jokes let's keep
watching the show there's a show called
too cute too cute yeah
and that's sweet hit the info button and
it said adorable puppies temporarily
distract you from your crumbling
marriage and finally Shahs of Sunset the
Shahs of Sunset I hit the info button
and it said for those whose main
complaint about Jersey Shore was not
hairy enough
[Applause]